what i thought i wanted to do was um
give
a very uh broad introduction to the
topic of natural selection and
adaptation
so i'll talk about some of the common
methods people are using to detect
natural selection and also a bit of
about the models that people are doing
are using to detect
natural selection and model natural
selection in general
and the target audience for this is
really people that come from
mathematical sciences that have
very little no background in population
genetics
and give you a flavor for how population
geneticists are thinking about these
different problems and i would say
since i covered many different topics i
would more sort of give you some
things that you could go and learn about
later and look up rather than actually
going in depth
very much with each topic so hopefully
you'll be able to live with that but
it's a very broad
topic and it's certainly something that
you could teach several semesters about
just this topic there's
thousands and thousands of papers on
natural selection you already heard a
lot about natural selection
i know when steve evans was covering
the fusion models he was talking about
natural selection
here for the speciation discussion by
chuck langley he was also talking a lot
about various forms of uh
natural selection uh so you already
heard some about that
and hopefully um this will help uh sort
of put things together in terms of how
do population geneticists think about
think about this
so i'm going to start in at the most
basic level what you would have learned
if you're taking an introductory course
in evolution what would you have learned
about
models of natural selection there so the
very simplest model
we can use i can see my slides are
getting screwed up here
well um that we could
use maybe we'll go to the diploid model
and since the slides
then almost seamless model we could use
it would be a simple detailed model
where we have two alleles
in it so there are three possible
genotypes calculate capillary cavity
lowercase a and lowercase a lowercase a
if the frequency of the capillary allele
is p
then by hardy-weinberg equilibrium we
can if there's random mating predict the
frequencies of these three genotypes in
the population
what is different from natural selection
from other models is
we break with the idea about
exchangeability it's not so that the
expected number of offspring
from each individual is independent of
the genotype but that
there's some fitnesses where the
expected number of offspring in the next
generation
depends on the genotype of the
individual so when we talk about natural
selection very sort of broadly verbal
definition
would be that uh individuals the
expected number of offspring the next
generation
depends on your genotype okay so the
fact that some individuals
have many offspring other have fewer
offspring next generation that's not
natural selection itself
except if it's because of some heritable
differences between
these uh individuals okay so
when we assign fitnesses we often like
to do it in terms of a
selection coefficient and one way it's
done sometimes in the diploid model it's
like this
you standardize with respect to one
individual say that individual has
fitness one
and then uh one genotype so the cavalla
cavalla
for example in this case has fitness one
the heterozygous has fitness one plus hs
where
s then is selection coefficients and h
is a dominance factor
and the lowercase a lowercase a
genotype has fitness one plus s so when
people talk about
selection coefficients they come from
this this is one
parametrization they're different other
ways of doing it as well
we can then um so what are these
fitnesses
right now you can think of them as just
simply viability the chance of surviving
uh to the to the age of reproduction
okay
um we can calculate then the average
fitness of the po in the population by
taking the frequency
of each genotype multiplying by the
fitness of that genotype
and then summing all genotypes and from
that
we can then easily calculate the
expected allele frequency in the next
generation by um
taking the frequency of the capillary
capillary individuals
multiplying them with a fitness and half
the frequency of the heater cycles
and multiply with their fitness and
standardized then with the average
fitness and the population that will
give us their little frequency in the
next generation
okay so that's uh sort of the simple
deployment model that you might start
hearing about if you
were taking an introductory course in
evolution or maybe in population
genetics
okay so um i'm gonna introduce some work
that evolutionary biologists like to use
when they talk about models like this
so for example when they talk about
directional selection
that means that one of the
alleles are always favored so that the
fitness of one homozygous
genotype is larger equal to the fitness
of the heterozygous type
that's larger equal to the thickness of
the
other homozygous type okay in a special
case
it's neutrality where all the fitness
are the same we don't usually include
that
in the condition for directional
selection so this is called directional
selection
because it favors uniquely one allele
and of course
what will happen in systems like this is
that uh
in the deterministic system that the
cavalier allele
uh will go to fixation eventually so
always increase in frequency
then you have this situation that's
called overdominance where the
heterozygous
have a fitness that higher than other
homozygous time
and of course in a system like that it's
very easy to convince yourself
and that there will be a stable
equilibrium
and the equilibrium point will then
depend on exactly what these uh
fitnesses are and then we have
a case that's not perhaps seen very
often in nature
which is on the dominance that's where
both of the homozygous types are
things are larger than the heterozygous
type and so then there will be
an unstable equilibrium point and either
the cavalry of the lowercase a
will be fixed in this deterministic
system so one way to look at it
is like this if you have the allele
frequency here p
there will be some point to the right of
that that little frequency will increase
to the left of that the little frequency
would decrease
you can also take the average fitness in
the population
and plot that that's what you have in
the blue curve and this illustrates
something
of importance which is that natural
selection will tend to increase the
average fitness of the population
which is one component of
what's known as fish's fundamental
theorem on natural selection
which says that the
increase in the
change in the real frequency is given by
uh
the variance additive genetic variance
uh in the
for fitness in in the population and uh
part of that is then that allele uh
changing little frequency will
always tend to increase fitness in the
population
all right so these are sort of the very
simplest models
that are that population geneticists
would use and introduce in an
undergraduate class
and then we'll talk about many other
types of selection okay
so um i'll just run through some of the
concepts that the pilots use when they
talk about different forms of selection
so
so far this election i was talking about
what's viability selection so it
operates on
survivorship but you could also have
fertility selection
that would operate on the level of
finding mates and
fitness operates on uh the p the pairs
that you made up with to produce
offspring in the next
generation and lots of different models
of fertility selection
okay related to that is sexual selection
which is a selection
related to actually finding mates so
that
the chance of finding a mate depends on
your genotype then there will be sexual
selection
and the geosexual selection goes all the
way back to um to diamond
who used that you have sexual selection
to explain some of the extreme
traits you see in there simply in males
for example
the long filler of the peacock why would
a peacock have
you know this enormously long tail it
can barely fly it's
subject to predation well the idea the
verbal
argument that darwin gave was that well
um if first a female tend to prefer
males with long tails then
males that have long tails in average
will produce more offspring
and therefore natural select or sexual
selection will favor males
with long tails okay so fischer then
formalize this and show that you can get
this runaway process where
this will so there will be this reef
force effect where you will keep
selecting more and more more for our
longer and longer tails
of the peacock until at one point
the fitness disadvantage of having the
long tail
this that you're subject to so much more
protection will work against it and the
and the process will stop but that is a
fish's
runaway model of sexual selection so in
real
life in many of the traits we're
interested in sexual selection is very
important but i'm
not going to talk more about it here
then we also have various other models
of for example frequency dependent
selection fluctuating selection that
differs
which from the model i talked about
before by allowing fitnesses to change
through time
frequency dependent selection your
fitness depend on the allele frequency
okay so that's a type of model as
relevant for example for interactions
between
parasites or pathogens and their hosts
okay where if you are a common parasite
or
pathogen the population might gain
immunity to you
and so you will be that type will be
selected against and there will be
less immunity against the rare types so
in that way uh selection will
depend on uh daniel frequency
fluctuating selection includes various
different models
that allow for various reasons selection
or the way selection operates to change
food time
so fitnesses get reassigned or somehow
changes through time and there's a lot
of
interesting dynamics with that something
that i think people working on the
mathematical side of population genetics
were very interested in
you know some years ago but has not
lately had so much focus as it used to
happen and i think there's a lot of
interesting
things i have to do with that for people
that are interested in or mathematical
problems
then something that's very very
important for understanding
uh social interactions and social
behavior is skin selection
so the idea is that um an allele
of certain type might give you a fitness
advantage it's not by
improving fertility or survivorship of
yourself
but of individuals that are related to
you so if i
i and there's a mutation arising in me
that will give
a increased fitness advantage to all my
siblings
but not to me that mutation will have a
last chance of spreading in the
population
because that will in the future
generation tend to be shared between my
siblings for example
so that fitness can operate not just on
the individuals
uh but also on uh individuals
that are related to to me or to another
individual okay so that's that's skin
selection and of course it's what's it's
important for is understanding things
like
apparent altruistic behavior animals
that live in social groups why are some
willing to sacrifice themselves for the
social group they live in that's
typically
most commonly explained because
it has related related individuals in
the group
that that it gives some some it
sacrificed some of its own fitness for
those individuals
and of course it's an extreme case of
that social insects
where uh some individuals that forego
reproduction altogether
so they don't reproduce at all and so
they have
in some sense they don't leave any
offspring next generation but because
the queen will leave more offspring next
generation traits
that favors that kind of behavior
are still advantageous we have also
other types of selection
group selection for example that's
models in which you um
selection acts on the level of the group
so you have a group of individuals
different groups of individuals and they
compete with each other those models are
usually a little harder
to make work but there's another set of
uh models that people are working on
very
rarely in nature i think to see group
selection without certain degree of
cancellation so i think most people
these days
not really an area i work in but i think
most people these days think that kin
selection is very common
but group selection without kidney
selection is probably very rare
and there are many more types of
selection chalk was talking about
selection at different levels where
you could have segregation disorders
it's another form of selection that can
spread through the
uh population so you get genomic
conflicts and so on and
so we have in very long list of
different ways of dif
different types of selection different
ways selection can operate
all right but after that i'm just going
to go back to our very simple models
hopefully convince you that we have you
know a rich and complicated world of
both now what i've given you verbal
models that also can be formalized
mathematically
but most of the time when population
geneticists work and most of the work
they're doing they think about very
simple models
such as this one here and um
you i know steve evans talked a lot
about simple models like that
how they can be incorporated into for
example the diffusion theory that we
often use
to understand population genetics so
to make things very simple uh
we can assume a multiplicative effect of
fitness genic selection
in which the fitnesses of the three
genotypes are one one minus
s and one minus s squared except very
close to one minus two s
okay in that case the diploid model
reduces to a haploid model
okay so now it's very easy to
incorporate selection in the models
you've heard about
in the right fischer model for example
uh instead of sampling
uh parents in the previous generation
with equal probability
you assemble them according to their
thicknesses proportional to the
fitnesses
and we can put that into the equations
we had before we'll get
a similar expression that a little
frequency in next generation
is given by this is the selection
coefficient defined like this
and the allele frequency in the previous
generation
um and then we can write that
as x plus x times 1 minus x times s plus
something that goes to zero if
when divided by s and s goes to uh
goes to zero so these are terms that
would vanish
if s is small we can then i'm just
reminding you of reviewing some of the
things that
steve talked about uh we can then get
some uh
we can then derive some diffusion
processes
so we can look at the expected change in
allele frequency
between two generations if we now scale
time in terms of n generations then
it'll be a time step of
size uh one divided by n
which is equal to from the previous line
x times one minus x times
s and we multiply and divide by two n so
gamma here is 2ns
and also we'll have a variance term that
comes from the binomial sampling
similarly and from that we can then
define
this or derive this diffusion process we
will have a term that has to do with the
with the variance uh and the terminus so
to
to do with uh the bias in the process
the the selection
here and from that what she was telling
you about was that a lot of things we
could do we can
look at if we introduce a new allele
with a certain selection coefficient
acting on it we can calculate
what's the expected time spent at a
certain frequency
how long time what's the expected time
until fixation
the expected time onto loss and so on
and um
probably most useful in many cases the
probability that we'll go to fixation
we can calculate that under on the
similar models like that
um and get very simple approximate
expressions for that
and that's being used for many many
different things that we're doing
in population genetics okay so that was
sort of
sort of the basic kind of very simple
model that
population geneticists use where you
have in this case two alleles you can
generalize it also to k alleles if you
want to
and so on but these two ideal models are
being used
a lot and the reason why they're good
for analyzing
population data dna sequence data is
often
interested in a new allele that's being
introduced in the population
and then the trajectory of that allele
and for that all we need is really a
true ideal model to be able to
understand that
so slowly moving towards
looking at um
at some of the models that people more
use for for analyzing data so the one
model that has become
very popular for analyzing dna sequence
data is
a a set of models called uh horizontal
random field models
were introduced first by sawyer and
hadley in 92.
and what they want to do is they want to
look at a process in which new mutations
arise as a constant
rate and time so you have a poisson
process at which new mutations arise
and then they follow the path of the
mutation then in time follow this
civil diffusion model and then you
integrate all paths and all times and
ask
okay what's the probability of seeing a
mutation out
with a certain frequency in a sample
okay so the way that that is done is
that you have some
density of allele frequencies and this
is not a
it's not a stationary distribution of
allele frequencies we are
operating here on an infinite science
model so mutations they introduce and
now go to fixation at laws but they
don't
there's no uh you know there's absolving
states there's no stationary
distribution here as such but we can
nonetheless
by looking at the time interval in which
you are or the amount of time you have
spent at a particular frequency on your
path to fixation or loss we can get a
the expected
proportion of alleles uh
yield frequencies in a certain category
if you exclude zero and one then station
g
you're looking for sorry well
g doesn't integrate the one g integrates
to infinity
so it's asymptotic well it's not a
stationary distribution right
i mean it's in the sense it's the sense
of the macro process with absorbing
states
states in the same it's not an economic
markov chain in that sense i mean that's
all i'm saying
but of course you can find it what does
have a distribution you can get is
the chance that uh you know some
probability on
on a random sample of annotation
conditional and segregating for example
if that's what you are at just that you
are still looking for a steady state
are you looking first okay yeah unless
you look at the steady state like
looking infinite amount of time you
introduce new mutations the path of each
mutation is described by markov chain
that with two absorbing states right and
then i look at
a particular point in time what's the
distribution of the little frequencies
of mutation at that point in time and
then integrate all the times
that's one way to think about it i mean
the markov chain doesn't converge to
equilibrium it goes to either zero or
one
so there's a there's two important
several important time scales
the answer is the f's there are two
important time scales one of them is
order
n and one is the order one over mu if
you go for times much bigger than m
then you get then you'll get this as a
transient
to the same right but much more than one
over mu
so if you think i mean anything well i'm
not sure where this green i mean my
statement about it not being exotic is
just the path of each single mutation
right so but i mean you could define all
the
functions of that process that has some
kind of
state distribution clearly
all right um
anyway so you can derive a density of
mutations
and then you assume uh you sample your
swim into a little model you sample
binomial from that
and then you integrate over the the
binomial distribution or that density
and that will give you a sample
distribution of what's the probability
of seeing uh the derived from the mutant
form
uh seeing a certain number at a certain
frequency
okay we can get that so now we can ask
we can
do things like this we can calculate
what's the
expected distribution of allele
frequencies
under different uh models under
different assumptions
so for example the classical you have a
standard neutral model so
under a standard diffusion process
without
selection and infinite size mutation
you'll get a distribution that's
proportional to 1 or x
now if you add selection to that
you'll get some different distributions
the distribution of a little frequency
will be skewed to the right
if you have positive selection and to
the left if you have negative
selection so as you say these
distributions are uh standardized
so that the they integrate uh two
um to one follow them of course there
will be if there's a lot of
selection you will actually have tend to
have for the same rotation rate fuel
mutation segregating at
at any point in time all right just to
make sure that everybody understand what
we're looking at here it's the same
length distribution where you imagine
you're taking
sample 20 chromosomes so if you deploy
10 copies of the dna
and then you look at what's the
frequency in the sample of mutations of
uh what's the proportion of of mutations
in the sample where the derived a little
segregate is a frequency of one out of
twenty
two out of twenty three out of twenty
and so on okay so we can derive these
distributions
one important thing to know what with
this is of course
beside all the simplifying assumptions
that we have made right now
of a constant population size and random
mating and so on
we're also making one additional
assumption here
what is that there's no interaction
between different
uh mutations okay so we just get the
marginal distribution for each mutation
real life there might be a interaction
between the mutations because they might
be sitting on the same chromosomes
that's something that's being known but
you can fit this to data so for example
this is from some data we analyzed a few
years ago of
um 200 exons so exome that's a part of
the
genome that calls for protein so you can
take it's easy and cheap now to pull out
all those part of the genome and
sequence that
for large number of individuals and then
you can look at the distribution of a
little frequency you see there so this
is for humans
for some europeans and um
what you have in the blue here is the
neutral expectation that once that's
proportional to one or x from before
and um then you have in the real data
two different distributions the green
one
is uh synonymous mutations and the
purple one that's non-synonymous
mutations and just let me remind you
what's the difference between synonymous
and non-synonymous
remember that there are there's central
dogma of molecular priorities that you
have dna that's been
transcribed to rna that's been
translated into protein
a triplet of three nucleotides codes for
one amino acid
uh in the protein okay so you have 64
possible triplets but they're only 20
amino acids so there's some redundancy
so you can have mutations two mutations
that occur in a coding region but the
resulting protein is not changed
okay so those are the synonymous
mutations the ones where you
where you have mutation that actually
change the protein those are the
non-synonymous mutation
we think mostly selection acts at the
level of the protein the proteins are
the ones that are doing the work
in the cell okay so most selections
should work at that level
so uh we often use the synonymous
rotation as a neutral standard as
what you would expect if there was no
natural selection and we see in this
particular case
that the for these data that the
synonymous and the neutral one are maybe
not so far away from each other
um but the non-synonymous ones they have
this strong excess
of rare alleles and that's exactly what
you would expect if many of them are
under
uh negative selection and you can then
take these horizon random field models
which are very simple and you can make
some even more assumptions about the
distribution form
of mutations and then get some kind of
estimate of how
much selection would you need to be able
to get such a difference between
synonymous and non-synonymous mutations
okay so this is for these type of data
you would find that about eighty percent
of all nonsense mutation need to be
under some kind of selection
to be able to explain the data so that's
a lot so um
many many many many mutations
segregating the human populations that
it's on the selection
right now okay so this is all
what i talked about so far what yeah
so this is this is honest uh assumption
of a gamma distribution of six electron
coefficient
plus a point mass at zero so just let
there be a point something that are
strictly neutral
so we have pointless zero and then uh an
additional gamma distributed number of
mutations that are
uh of minus s of selection coefficients
and then you ask how many for however
bigger proportion
of the probability mass go into the
gamma distribution how much to go into
the point and asset still
and you can use all distribution form
and you will get different answers but
i mean so i don't think you i would you
know uh
you know whether it's 80 or 75 percent
85
i don't think we really that will depend
on the distribution
i mean the general thing about the
distribution unless you have very very
large samples
this is entirely sensitive to ones where
the s is a border one over n
yeah so well so you can incorporate also
the ones that don't go to fixation
right so the fact you also have
information about the unbearable ones
so the ones that you see sick again so
the ones that you actually see
segregating in the population are the
ones where it's on the order of one or
in right
but there's also there's also
information here about mutations
that you never see segregating in the
population that information we also have
that
heaviness most mutations that are on the
selection
are many positions in which the mutation
that would be on the selection probably
we'll never see this anything
segregating there because the effect of
that mutation is so deleterious
so that's incorporated here as well in
the distance
okay all right so what
um i've been talking about so far what i
would call the direct effects
of uh natural selection on a mutation so
we're modeling
a particular mutation that's under
selection okay
but most of the pattern you would see in
real data is actually of
what you would call the indirect effects
of mutation that is the effects
of the selected mutations on nearby
neutral variants
and positions in the genome on which
there's no selection acting
and much work in population genetics
these days in the past maybe 15 20 years
have really focused on understanding
that pattern
not so much on the selection on the
notation themselves but the effect of
the selected mutations
on other variants that are not on the
selection okay so if you have an
advantageous rotation uh that occurs in
the population and increases in
frequency
and it goes to fixation in the end to
talk about a selective sweep
and just sort of a little intuitive way
of understanding what's going on
so you imagine here you have some dna
sequences that are segregated in the
population
every position where you have a star
means that there's a mutation there so
this is the derived allele in that
particular
position imagine that at some point in
time there's a new advantageous mutation
lands on a chromosome
if it's advantageous with some
probability eventually it will go to
fixation so all individuals in the
population will carry that mutation but
if there was no recombination
then it's not just that mutation that
goes to uh fixation it's all
the linked mutations these mutations
that were sitting on the same chromosome
at that potatoes mutation
okay so that's the pattern that we're
looking at we'll get this pattern where
the effect of the potatoes mutations not
just on itself or the selection on that
but it's also on the nearby sides
all right and i'm just going to remind
you about the process of recombination i
know
all the people talk about recombination
but really fundamental for understanding
anything in genetics
recombination so you have doing meiosis
you have the
paternal and maternal copies of the dna
and they can swap
dna between them the chromosomes that
you inherited from your mother and your
father so when
you produce gametes egg cell sperm cells
in my part of of the dna you pass on to
the next generation
for a particular chromosome part of it
might be from your mother and part of it
from your file
okay so that's the process of of
recombination which is
uh i know i could see from slides that
you have heard about before but i just
want to remind you
so because of that you can have a peel
called uh escape
by recombination you can imagine that
was a recombination event between say
this chromosome this chromosome here and
this mutation you have over here is
being put
on this chromosome so after this
advantageous mutation
has gone through fixation in this
position you still have the two alleles
that arrived and then system
once because of this recombination event
that occurred as the advantageous
mutation
increased in frequency in the population
okay so the pattern
so we'll go a little bit into one of the
models that people use to model that but
i just
first gotta explain a little bit about
the pattern that people expect to see
because of this
which is mainly a reduction in
variability
in the region around the advantageous
mutation and why is that that's because
right around the advantageous mutation
all mutations have either been lost
or gone through fixation together with
advantageous mutation
so if you look at the amount of
variables in the genome and there's been
a particular position in the genome
where there's been a selective sweep
like this
you will see this reduction variability
like that and it will also affect all
the
patterns in the data that i'll talk
about a little bit later
okay so the the
this idea go back all the way to a paper
by main smith and hate from 1974
but the modern way of thinking about
this problem and modeling it
can be i think traced back to uh this
paper by
kaplan helsin langley from 1989 so they
were interested in
and made one of the first uh models of
uh
coalescence models with the selection
and the way that we're modeling it is
that they were
dividing the problem and that's
something that's been used in many many
applications since then
dividing the problem into two parts the
first problem is what's the
trajectory of the selected allele futine
how does that change so that's what you
have here
depicted here and the second problem is
then
how does the genealogy then look
conditional
on that trajectory doing it like that
simplifies things a lot so what you have
here depicted in this figure is a
coalescence tree
for a linked neutral science and the way
we interpret it is that
if there was no recombination of course
all of the lineages would have to
coalesce at the time
at or before going backwards in time the
advantageous mutation approach at that
point there was only one copy of the dna
so if there's no recombination
all lines is what's called this back
there but if there's recombination
you can escape the selective sweep and
you might have a coalescence times
that's older
than that okay so what kevin harts and
langley did was
they divided the select the process of
selected sweep into three
uh status stage first in which the
allele frequency is very low
then an intermediate stage here in which
that real frequency increase
and then at this last stage in which
the little frequency is very high and
the reason why they did what that was
that they were saying okay this part of
the trajectory is almost deterministic
so let's model that using a
deterministic model and just then deal
with the stochasticity down here
and up there
okay so we have the three phases
um first a face at which a little is of
low frequency where the real frequencies
then model as a supercritical branching
process
that's a positive selection so it'll be
a supercritical uh
process okay and that deal then is
an idea that subsequently has used a lot
is that um
that when the allele frequency is very
very low you can model
the distribution of a little frequencies
using
uh essentially assuming independence so
you can model it using
birth death processes or the trees using
a simple branching process
as the little frequency becomes larger
that doesn't work anymore but for lower
allele frequency
lower little frequencies that work then
you have the deterministic change that's
the same equation
slightly different formulas we've seen
before now as a deterministic
change through time and then you model
the
one minus the allele frequency as a
sub-critical branching process
as you get to very high uh
allele frequencies okay so you have
those three phases
now what do you do then conditional on
the
the collision process conditional on the
allele frequency
okay so then you use that's another
thing that people have been using
a lot subsequently is that you use a
structured coalition then i know you
already heard about structured
coalitions processes so those are the
processes you usually would use
when you have you know two or more
themes or sub-populations
here you can think of the subpopulations
as being the different allele classes
the neutral allele linked to the
selected allele and the neutral allele
not linked to the selected allele
and then you can model conditional
nanolineal frequency
trajectory you can model the collisions
process
as a timing
in homogeneous markov jump process with
the following rates
so you'll have coalescences in one elite
class
at the usual rate uh if there are i
individual i choose two
but then divided uh standardized not by
only by the population size you need to
standardize with
is the allele frequency times the
population size
in that allele class the other leader
class is the same you have coalescence
this occur at the same rate as you
normally would but you need to
standardize by the ideal frequency of
that allele class
and then you also have what takes a role
of
migration events between the two
populations and that's recombination
events
that occur at rates that are
proportional to the number of
uh alleles in that elite class and then
also proportional to every combination
rate that so this is exactly like a
stronger coalescence model you just
instead of having
um instead of having migration you have
recombination
here all right
so coalescence trees how will they look
well if this is a
normal neutral coalescence tree that
look like that on the selector sweep
what this type of one would predict is
that you'll have something like this
you'll have a short selective face as
that advertises a little increasing
frequency
many of the lineages are forced to
collision during that time period but
then by recombination some most
some make can escape so you'll get
treats that may look
something like like this for lessons
trees and then also
you can now distribute mutations on
those trees
and then predict what the distribution
of a little frequencies then would be
and you'll get something like what you
see in the yellow
columns if you take a window around the
selector suite you will find that there
increase in mutations of low frequency
and on high frequency
these are the ones that hitchhike with
advantageous mutation these are the ones
that where selection that would
initially were not linked with that
rotators mutation so they decreased in
frequency
okay so you get sort of this bimodal
distribution
of alleles all right
so there's been a lot of work on these
models
um um
so wolfgang stefan for example has done
lots of work on these models and
one of the thing he was doing in some of
this model was saying okay this
stochastic
the stochastic phase doesn't really
matter much because a little frequency
there is so low there's not much
opportunity of recombination anyway
so we kind of ignore that so let's uh
focus on the deterministic model and
then
if you do that things become easier you
can derive a lot of
interesting results other people have
been looking at
what's happened more during this lecture
phase and what's the
chance what's can you get a probability
distribution
of the number of lineages that are
actually called this during the
selective space and there's for example
a paper right
by rick red and schweinsberg in 2004
where they show that there's a limit in
which the number of
lineages that are forced to call this is
simply binomial
and so you can from that it becomes very
very easy to do various kind of
calculations if you work in that limit
because uh you have
you know certain lineages that will look
like as if there hadn't been selection
and there are certain dimensions that
are all for forced to coalesce with this
binomial probability of course this is
an approximation that no it's not the
fact that
in fact all the linears don't collision
the same time uh
but they will collis at different times
in different clusters
and there lots of work also on on that
on sort of the theory of
coalescence process with multiple
murders mergers in the context
of um selective sweeps and these are
some of the references to some of that
one
okay all right so so this is so i just
want to talk a little bit about the
generally about the coalescence
approaches to to selection so
what we saw here was that what what
was done was that you took the
conditioned on the allele frequency
and the trajectory of allele frequencies
and then you would have a coalescence
process
that runs like a normal coalescence
process within each allele class
okay and then you could by recombination
go between these little classes
that kind of way of using a structured
coalescence conditioning on ideal
frequency has been used many many times
it's a common way
of dealing with natural selection that's
convenient when there are
fewer allelic classes and for example
for a certain type of very strong
balancing selection balancing selection
a selection that maintains variability
in the population
where you don't predict that there's
much of a change of a little frequency
to full time
these type of approaches are
particularly appealing and
lead to simple results then there's
another type of approach
which is um where people use uh
again for example linear birth death
processes for rare alleles so as i
talked about before
you can model the the change in little
frequency or equivalently
the coalescence process using models
that assume essentially independence
among the lineages
um as long as the allele frequency is
very low that that works so then
number of papers on that finally
there's this set of approaches which use
what's called the ancestral uh
selection graph and i'll just end up
this to talk a little bit about
ancestral selection graph okay so this
is a sort of a full
coalescence model for selection i would
say uh
maybe a little bit more principled
approach perhaps
why is it why is it hard to do the
coalescence will selection well
it's hard because we're seeing that the
rate of coalescence depends on which
lily class that you're in
and you need to know the leading class
and that this
furthermore depends on what's the
population frequency of that analytic
class
which usually will be unknown okay and
can change full time
so the weight in the ancestor selection
graph to deal with that is
that you're gonna stick in some extra
fake branches
in the coalescence string these branches
are gonna essentially mimic the
the uh effect of selection so if you
know that you have
five cavallae alleles and five lowercase
alleles and note that capital alleles
are strongly
favors then you would expect looking
backwards in time coalescences
occurring at a higher rate among the
cavalier alleles okay
and looking forward in time if you look
at the reverse process starting
at an ancestor of a tree it might be
more intuitive to realize that
if you have two lineages one that
carries the
uh favored allele and one that have the
unfavorable you would expect more
populations or more splitting of
lineages more
um branching of lineages for the favor
of the deal and for the unfavorable
okay so you can deal with that problem
rigorously by putting in fake branches
in the coalescence tree
where you'll have to make a choice
between which branch you actually should
choose
depending on which allele is assigned to
that branch
so you'll now instead not you'll
simulate
um if you want to simulate a process
like this the way you would do it is
you would simulate collisions events
like normally so they occur at
rate j times j minus one or two or j
two's two
if they're j limitations but then the
new thing is you have branching events
that occur at a rate uh sigma j divided
by two this is
uh this selection parameter two and s
the same thing as
uh gamma from before in in the very
simplest models
and then so these if you look at this
tree for example this
genealogy here you have this branching
event here and then you label the two
new branches
uh one as being the incoming branch and
then
and another one as being the
contributing brands what is it called
the
incoming branch and the contributing
brains i think
um continuing brains thanks continuing
brains
okay and so the next thing you want to
do you want to then
put mutations on the tree including both
the continuing and the incoming branch
and then what you do is that you first
start at the most recent common ancestor
of the entire sample so at the at the
roots and then you choose the allelic
state there
according to the stationary distribution
okay so you assign a linux state there
and then you put mutations on the tree
as you usually do
use using if you're on the infinite
science model poisson process or some
other rotational process
uh along the sewand post that on the
edges
of the coalition's graph
and then what you want to do is after
you assign that you want to choose
well you should erase an incoming
or continue contributing
continuing continuing branch and
incoming our continuing branch and that
will depend on their leading states
that then has been assigned to those so
if there's a conflict
between these two branches so they have
different
unique states you always choose the
leading states of the favorite allele
okay so you can show that that correctly
generates
the coalescence tree will selection
now a couple of so so you in some sense
you have a fantastic
framework here rigorous framework for
you know describing the coalescence
process with selection why hasn't it
been
used so much well one of the main
reasons is that
um computationally it can only deal with
quite weak selection at least in the way
it's formulated here
so you have coalescences that occur at a
rate that's
about uh quadratic and you have
branchings that
eventually occur at linearly with
that's linearly the rate of that is
linear in the number of linears that
will guarantee that eventually
you'll get to a most common ancestor
four lineages of down to one lineage
but if this coefficient here is high
it can take a very very very long time
as soon as you're down to very few
lineages
um you could get you still have um
could have a high rate of branching so
you will
have to wait a very very long time until
you're back to just having one image
and in practice you know if if sigma
here gets
to be 10 or larger this becomes starts
to become very computational
uh bubble sum and
so that's one of the main reasons why by
this framework despite
its you know as appealing as this
mathematically
perhaps has not been used very often by
actually making inferences
in population genetics this object the
same as the ancestral recombination
graph
not you're going left and right no
depending on
time no no no no this is completely now
this is completely different in there i
mean it's a branching process and
the rate of branching is the same if you
have
yeah um
yeah i mean the similarities in that
sense yeah but i mean the
i mean it's fundamentally different this
that you actually don't know so this is
this
you know where you delete either the
incoming or the continuing graph that
will actually give you the
a coalescence tree for marginally for
one particular perspective
position position so but so it gives you
a trick
yeah but this is just about one position
this is just a
one position and so yes you look at one
particular position
and this is actually this is not a graph
that represents the ancestry this would
be one that represent the answer so you
have to delete these
edges of the graph
edges right they're just giving you
something that
is like it's like device produces the
selection
yeah sort of meaning in terms of
genealogies yeah
all right so so i think
you know perhaps if you're a
mathematician i think these type of
models
and seeing other ways you know others
how can we better deal with these kind
of problems where the
the the size of the graph doesn't
explode as we look at stronger
selections
um in the structure called there's an
approach yes well
usually people have not been doing that
but you can do that because you can
you can simulate the marginal tree for
one side that's selected
and then conditional nets simulate for
the trees with every combination graph
and that has been done a little bit but
not much because it's kind of
complicated and cumbersome to do
the structure coalescence is also used
not just for linkage i mean it is used
for just also looking marginally at one
at one side so the uh in which case
the rate of um
you can put instead of recombination
mutation where you can take one
from the other instead of its
recombination this mutation event they
take you from one class to another class
so for balancing selection that will be
the usual interpretation
all right so i think we should take a
break now
if there are no more questions